ADMINISTRATION SAYING THEY LEFT
A DISMANTLED AND UNWORKABLE
SYSTEM.
MARK MEREDITH PICKS UP OUR
COVERAGE FROM THE WHITE HOUSE.
COVERAGE FROM THE WHITE HOUSE.WA
AND UNPREPARED SYSTEM BECAUSE
OF THE RULE OF THE LAST
ADMINISTRATION.
IT WILL TAKE TIME BUT WE’RE
CLEAR EYED ABOUT WHAT THE
PROBLEMS ARE AND VERY FOCUSED
ON PUTTING FORWARD SOLUTIONS.
>> ONE OF THOSE SOLUTIONS
HAVING FEMA SHELTERING AND
SUPPORTING UNACCOMPANIED MINORS.
THEY’RE NOT ASKING FOR MORE
MONEY TO DEAL WITH IT.
BUT THEY HAVE A MESSAGE FOR
MIGRANTS CONSIDERING CROSSING.
>> NOW GIVE US THE TIME TO
REBUILD THE SYSTEM THAT WAS
ENTIRELY DISMANTLED IN THE
PRIOR ADMINISTRATION AND WE
HAVE, IN FACT, BEGUN TO REBUILD
THAT SYSTEM.
>> THE WHITE HOUSE DOES WANT
CONGRESS TO PASS COMPREHENSIVE
IMMIGRATION REFORM.
REPUBLICANS SAY THIS IS A
CRISIS CREATED BY THIS WHITE
HOUSE AFTER PRESIDENT BIDEN’S
DECISION TO REVERSE SO MANY OF
THE TRUMP-ERA BORDER POLICIES.
>> HE CAN CONTINUE TO DENY IT.
THE ONLY WAY TO SOLVE IT IS TO
FIRST ADMIT WHAT HE HAS DONE.
AND IF HE WILL NOT REVERSE
ACTION, IT WILL TAKE
CONGRESSIONAL ACTION TO DO IT.
>> SO FAR THE WHITE HOUSE HAS
NOT ANNOUNCED ANY PLANS FOR
PRESIDENT BIDEN TO VISIT THE
BORDER.
HE WILL BE GOING ON THE ROAD
STARTING TODAY HEADING TO
CHESTER, PENNSYLVANIA, RIGHT
OUTSIGHT PHILLY TO TALK ABOUT
THE STIMULUS BILL HE SIGNED
INTO LAW LAST WEEK FOCUSING ON
WHAT SMALL BUSINESSES CAN DO TO
KEEP PEOPLE ON THE PAYROLL.
YOU CAN BET A LOT OF QUESTIONS